what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back once again with another
installment of our beyond omega level
series where we break down the most
powerful characters in all of comics and
as is often the case we are focusing
this week on one aspect of the marvel
cosmic hierarchy as we're talking about
marvel's embodiment of the void of the
universe oblivion now oblivion was
created by jmd matthias and alan
kupperberg and first appeared in iceman
number one in 1984. i know it's a weird
place to appear but just bear with me so
oblivion's origins can be traced back
further than that of the marvel
multiverse itself and in fact to the
time when all that existed was an entity
called the first universe who out of his
loneliness was motivated to create two
sets of cosmic beings the aspirants
which were totally devoted to the first
firmament and worshipped it and the
celestials who were more interested in
acquiring knowledge and evolving now
these two factions would eventually end
up fighting in the celestial war which
basically shattered the first universe
and then nearly destroyed it but the
pieces of the first universe would later
become the first multiverse also known
as the second cosmos now following this
the multiverse would be destroyed and
reborn again and the first universe
would later create four entities
infinity eternity death and oblivion
which collectively represent the tension
between life and death throughout any
one particular universe now although all
four of these entities are technically
considered siblings oblivion and death
share an especially close connection and
some have hypothesized that the two are
actually just aspects of the same entity
most of the time oblivion inhabits a
vast pocket dimension without matter or
energy simply known as the outer void
which is coincidentally where you end up
if you are erased from existence by the
ultimate nullifier one of the most
powerful artifacts in all of marvel
that's thought to be an aspect of
galactus himself now as far as what his
powers are like most of the cosmic
entities that we talk about in the
series oblivion's powers are almost
limitless and i'm not exaggerating at
all when i say that in this true form
oblivion is one of the most powerful
characters in marvel comics and is
practically omnipotent and nearly
omnipresent in fact if one were to
actually see the true form of oblivion
they would simply cease to exist and so
for that reason he takes on a form that
others can observe even though he does
not technically have a physical form now
oblivion is able to manipulate reality
and uses beings as powerful as galactus
and the screer a being that claims to be
older than galactus as his pawns
oblivion has a long-standing rivalry
with his sibling infinity and when the
two of them battle they do so on the
highest plane of reality because if they
were to battle in the physical universe
it would cause galaxies to collide with
one another now because oblivion doesn't
really exist on the physical plane he
usually employs heralds or avatars to do
his bidding and some of these avatars
have been incredibly powerful in their
own right one of them is death urge who
is basically marvel's version of dc's
black racer and that he is an entity
that functions much in the same way as
the grim reaper bringing death to all
that he touches and is also able to
travel at incredible speeds that is
until oblivion was so upset at death
urge's inability to capture squirrel
girl's pet squirrel monkey joe that he
banished him to the physical plane in
the form of a squirrel
another of oblivion's avatars is
maelstrom the son of an inhuman named
fader and a deviant named morga now
maelstrom would become a brilliant
scientist that swears to enact revenge
on the inhumans for banishing his father
now he would later find out about
oblivion and become his avatar aiding
oblivion in his mission to rid the
multiverse of all life but the best
known of oblivion's avatars are probably
amatsu mikabashi also known as the chaos
king now if you're not familiar with the
chaos king i encourage you to go check
out the beyond omega level video that we
did about him here on the channel or the
video where we covered his old story arc
but to give you guys a brief explanation
mikibashi is the japanese god of evil
within the marvel multiverse and during
one of his first appearances he's
presented as a threat to mount olympus
the home of the greek pantheon of gods
and what we later learn is that the
chaos king was inspired by the fall of
asgard during ragnarok to take as many
pantheons of gods as he possibly can and
what we would see throughout his
appearances is that the chaos king is
one of the most formidable threats the
marvel multiverse had ever seen not only
was he able to kill zeus with no trouble
at all but he nearly destroyed the
entire multiverse during the events of
the chaos war storyline which was
amazing of course i've also explained
that here on the channel even some of
the most powerful characters in marvel
comics including hercules galactus and
silver surfer were unable to kill the
chaos king but he was ultimately
defeated when he was sent to an
alternate dimension but as powerful as
the chaos king was oblivion states that
the reason for his failure was that
chaos king was but one aspect of
oblivion himself which would mean that
oblivion is vastly more powerful than
even the chaos king now it's also been
speculated that another extremely
powerful villain null the god of the
symbiotes is himself an aspect of
oblivion although i don't think this has
been officially confirmed by marvel but
this idea comes from the instance where
jean grey used her telepathic abilities
on null and concludes that although he
comes from darkness he is not darkness
himself as the darkness existed before
no which led many readers to conclude
that the darkness she's referring to is
oblivion and if null is an aspect of
oblivion that gives us even more
evidence of his immense power because
all the heroes of earth were unable to
defeat null even with the century being
effortlessly ripped in half by null
until the unit power showed up to
basically save the day but whether or
not null is actually an aspect of
oblivion we still know that he's far
beyond omega level but oblivion is one
of marvel's most powerful entities which
is why we rarely see him in action as
any battles with him would end in
humiliating defeat for the heroes tasked
with taking him down but let me know
what you guys think do you wish that we
saw oblivion more often i'm kind of
curious but we're going to bring this to
an end thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace